[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the tim ferriss show
my guest today is jane mcgonagall you
can find her on twitter at avant game a
v a n t game jane is a future forecaster
and a world-renowned designer of
alternate reality games that improve
real lives and solve real problems she's
the director of games research and
development at the institute for the
future and the lead instructor for their
series on the coursera platform she also
teaches the course how to think like a
futurist we're going to dig into some of
the frameworks i imagine at stanford
university jane is the new york times
bestselling author of reality is broken
and super better and her newest book is
imaginable subtitle how to see the
future coming and feel ready for
anything even things that seem
impossible today and we'll get into some
of her exercises
and also simulations and it might be
pretty eerie and amazing so we will get
to that her ted talks on how games can
make a better world and the game that
can give you 10 extra years of life have
more than 15 million views so jelly so
jelly jan that's a lot of views her
innovative games and ideas have been
recognized by the world economic forum
harvard business review fast company mit
technology review o magazine and the new
york times among many others you can
find all things jane on her website jane
mcgonagall m-c-g-o-n-i-g-a-l
dot com
jane welcome back to the show it's nice
to see you thank you tim it's really
nice to see you
now i thought i would just immediately
make this super self-indulgent and
use this opportunity to ask you about
sleep
because i know that we have spoken about
sleep before
but for me and i'm sure a lot of people
recently my insomnia has just been going
for extra credit and
typically there are two causes i would
say one is just too much caffeine not
much i'm going to ask you about that
that is something i should just
self-regulate the other one is
a
hyperactive high rpm
just mental processing that happens and
it sometimes it makes sense sometimes
this doesn't but the feeling that i'm
laying down and my brain just will not
turn off
and i know that you have experimented
with various things before bed
have you any recommendations for me or
anyone else listening
i have two recommendations one
uses video games and one uses the future
so the video game one pretty
easy
video games allow us to control our
thoughts and imagination right they
focus our attention on
a problem that isn't real right it's a
game and we can
be swapping candy tiles or catching
pokemon or whatever we're doing in the
game and it allows us to shut down
the busy thoughts the hyper mental
stimulation and it does seem to be
pretty effective as a bedtime
routine the only side effect is that you
might
dream or hallucinate about the game when
you fall asleep so you might see those
tetris blocks falling when you close
your eyes but that's not not too bad a
side effect is you know better than
ambien i think
yeah i imagine so and
i just wanted to to layer onto that
really quickly because you also
mentioned in our last conversation
how
tetris can be used
to mitigate post-traumatic stress
disorder and in a sense kind of visually
overwriting what could become
a sort of compulsive repetitive
cycle of imagery caused by the trauma
itself and that really struck me
do you have any games that you favor for
this if you were going to be using a
game before bed and for how long would
you suggest
yes good practical questions first some
good news uh the researchers at oxford
university who first did that study
about using tetris to prevent unwanted
flashbacks from traumatic events
they had previously done the studies in
the lab
they actually started testing it in the
field for people who had experienced
violence
or accidents that sent them to the
emergency room and they were able to
replicate the findings in the field
since we last talked so there's even
more evidence that it works
for
preventing ptsd or just for bedtime 10
minutes is the dose that's been tested
and so it's not you know i mean it's
pretty easy just to pull out
your phone
i've been using lately quartal
i don't know this quartal is the super
masochistic version of wordle which
everybody's been playing how do you
spell what is it quartal quartal
quartal q-u-o-r-d-l-e
so it's just like wordle where you have
five guesses to get a five letter word
except you're doing four words at the
same time with the same guesses so you
have to allocate your guesses to try to
maximize information
about all four words and you're looking
at all four words and i do it every
night before i go to bed now
and it's it's great i mean you literally
can't think about anything else while
you're trying to solve
four five letter words at the same time
wow so i interrupted because
i have no tact and just wanted to talk
about the ptsd from the last
conversation and segway
from that
into your recommendation related to
games you said you had another
recommendation related to the future
yeah so you and i have talked before
about this mantra that a lot of
futurists have i think it's in one of
your books that in order to look forward
we try to look back at least twice as
far and look for patterns in the past
and human culture and history and there
have been a lot of people talking lately
about a past pattern of sleep i don't
know if you have come across
this so before we invented electricity
the normal human sleeping pattern was to
be awake in the middle of the night for
two to three hours and people used to
sleep in what they called first sleep
and then they would be awake and they
would do stuff they would often do
chores or have intimate conversations
with whoever was sharing the bed with
them which wasn't always a partner
because people used to share beds with
you know
more people family members yeah and then
they would after a few years they would
go back to sleep for a second sleep and
it seems like a lot of people if your
insomnia is when you're falling asleep
you know do the game thing but if your
insomnia is in the middle of the night
you may actually just be more in tune
with natural human sleeping patterns and
the rest of us because of the type of
stimulation our brain gets from electric
light or artificial light
we
have a weird you know modern sleeping
pattern but it i find that a lot of
people
can relax in that middle of the night
awakeness and i've definitely gone
through periods of my life where i've
fallen back into that two sleep cycle
and if you know that it's natural and
actually
kind of the original human sleeping
pattern it can take away some of the
anxiety and you just if you can get
amazing stuff done in the middle of the
night while everyone else is asleep and
if we can kind of let go of the
the like worry this is weird something's
wrong with me i have to fix it and think
about you know maybe in the future we'll
go back to the way we used to sleep in
the past and or or not try to force
people out of it maybe it will just be
like two ways of sleeping
yeah
i've always done my best writing
in the middle of the night
two
three in the morning and uh fortunately
in my case or unfortunately it's onset
something yeah so it sounds like i
should i should try the game
do you know why
the oxford researchers chose
tetris did they test other games and
then choose tetris was just the ubiquity
and kind of simplicity awareness of the
game what was the reason
so the main reason is that tetris is
widely known to be the most visually
stimulating video game that has ever
been designed and what what the
researchers were trying to do was
essentially to take over the visual
processing center of the brain because
unwanted flashbacks the the reason we
experienced them is that in the
heightened
emotional period after
a trauma our brain keeps replaying it
over and over again especially in this
incredibly intense visual form of
imagination
and if it gets
really locked in
during those first 24 hours it
essentially becomes a pattern for the
brain that is very hard to disrupt and
there are therapies but people will go
to therapies for years to try to break
that pattern and if you can stop it
first it helps so so tetris and
everybody you know you've had this
experience you close your eyes you see
the falling breaks
there are other games at work candy
crush is great you know any any visual
pattern matching game where your brain
is looking at colors looking at shapes
looking at how things are arranged in
space
will be really good
quartal works for me because i'm not
i mean i wouldn't use chordal for a
trauma but it works for me for insomnia
but depending on how much
if you're trying to stop
visual thoughts you know like if you
have a really vivid imagination the
visual games will work better and if
it's just sort of abstract thoughts
you know you can you can really play any
game that you like
so let's segue to
the foreshadowing to nostradamus
mcgonagall to
make
oh my god i love it i'm getting a
t-shirt that's so sad
oh man
if so please describe
what happened
when you led more than 20 000 gamers in
a simulation in 2010 because it is it is
pretty spooky
right
okay so i should just very quickly
explain that one of the kinds of games
that i specialize in creating
is something called a social simulation
which is where you get thousands of
people to spend several days or weeks
on a on a
fictional social network so basically
build like facebook from the future or
twitter from the future and people come
and they share
messages and photos and videos and
stories about what's happening but it's
all imagined ten years in the future and
to get people all imagining the same
future we give them scenarios so we say
okay it's 10 years in the future and one
of the
one of the most popular
simulations i created we ran it in 2010
with the world bank
and it was set 10 years in the future so
the year 2020
and we asked them to imagine a series of
cascading global crises and how would
they feel what would they do how would
they adapt how would they try to help
others and it started with a respiratory
pandemic that started in china
and then there was a misinformation and
conspiracy theory group called citizen x
that started to spread all kinds of
crazy information and people couldn't
figure out what was really going on and
they weren't trusting the government and
then they started experiencing historic
wildfires on the west coast due to
climate change i mean it was essentially
everything that we actually lived
through
in 2020 but back then it was it was
fictional it was hypothetical and
we asked people you know
first of all we want to just get some
collective intelligence like
let's say you've been told to isolate
for
for two weeks i can't go to work can't
go to school can't go out under what
circumstances would you break this order
right is there something that would
make you feel compelled to go out even
if you've been told not to
you're contagious you're at risk and the
number one thing people said was for
religious services you know because it's
so deeply ingrained in their values and
the community is so important to them we
also heard weddings funerals and of
course these turned out to be
the super spreading events the hardest
to shut down
when the real pandemic happened people
said you know i'm worried about
schools being closed and how i'm going
to work and take care of my kids at the
same time if suddenly we can't send them
to school anymore a lot of women express
concern that they would be the ones
who'd have to stop working
of course in 2020 there was a historic
exodus of women from the workforce to
take care of kids home from school and
what was really interesting is the
players back then
were able to
effectively imagine what they would feel
and need and do and predict
a lot of things that during the actual
pandemic people said were surprising you
know we asked people
we ran another simulation
called quarantine
back in 2008 looking at the year 2019
and we asked people during that
simulation to wear masks we gave them
masks we sent out masks and we said just
try and wear these in your everyday life
and like what is it like and how
comfortable is it how socially awkward
is it when do you you know when do you
really need to take the mask off and and
would you be able to adapt to it and
what we heard you know was it was going
to be very hard to adapt and there were
so many social norms in the way and the
physicality of it and the
the difficulty of expressing our
emotions and feelings and connecting to
others
and you know so we're like great even
though it sounds like a really
rational
intervention during a pandemic when the
real pandemic rolled around we're like
this is going to be really tricky and
people aren't going to want to do it and
so i mean it was just it's just amazing
how much we could learn
that when the real pandemic happened and
all the other intersecting crises people
said well that was unimaginable or that
was unthinkable but no people are
experts on their own futures and if you
ask them before the crisis happens
before the disruption happens
you can get really actionable evidence
but tim can i tell you
what for me is the most important thing
that happened as a result of all these
people simulating tell me all the things
and then i have many follow-up questions
on this story please continue
so you know i started hearing from
people
at the start of 2020
i mean people at the world bank who had
worked on the simulation and they were
like uh are we reporting out are we like
following up because the world looks
exactly like we imagined but also from
participants from players and they were
writing me very early on before most
people were even paying attention to
what was going on they told me like you
know ever since that that game pandemics
have just been on my radar it's like i
pick up the information faster than
other people i noticed the change faster
they were they were writing me in early
january when most people were not really
thinking this was going to affect them
outside of china
people were
writing me throughout 2020 saying you
know
this has been terrible but i feel like i
experienced
less anxiety and depression than my
friends and family i i felt less shocked
it didn't take me as long to accept
reality i mean tim i don't know if you
remember
we were fighting reality early in this
process people did not want to change
businesses did not want to send their
workers home i mean i think a lot of
people are still fighting reality but
yes
and the thing that i spent like the last
two years studying all of the people who
participated how they suffered less
during the real crisis and it wasn't
even necessarily like well some people
avoided getting sick better than others
but it was it was that the first feeling
they had the first emotion they had when
this all happened
was pre-recognition which is an
incredibly positive emotion it's like
you said nostradamus right that feeling
of having been right i knew this could
happen i saw this coming
that makes us feel smart it makes us
feel capable confident powerful even
when we're in
all all this uncertainty
and disruption and
having that be your brain's first
reaction to a new
adverse situation it turned out was
really powerful and it it allowed people
to feel less shock not get frozen not be
in denial overcome normalcy bias faster
and get on with adapting and helping
themselves and others
we're gonna of course get into
many facets of
seeing the future coming or seeing
envisioning the future coming different
tools different games
but let me double click for a second of
this 2010
uh simulation so there are two questions
that i have the first is
how did you
or how did the team or how did someone
else arrive on these particular
scenarios
and then
the second question is what other
scenarios were there if any that did not
come true or that have not yet come true
okay good
so
let's see i mean so there were really
two big simulations we were running at
the time one was super struct which i
was running with researchers at the
institute for the future and the other
was evoke which i was running with the
world bank and i would say that one of
the biggest inputs into deciding what
scenario to simulate
was a new resource that that had just
been published for the first time the
world economic forum published its first
annual
report on global threats which they now
do every year but this was the first
time they published it and they were
asking business leaders government
leaders creative people the smartest
people they could find the most powerful
people they can find and ask them what's
keeping you up at night
how
likely do you think
you know the things that are keeping you
up at night are to happen they ask
really smart questions like what do you
think is the most under
rated or underappreciated risk or threat
where it's more likely than people think
it's going to have a bigger impact than
people think and by the way i want to
share with you
what was recently reported as the most
underrated risk because i am
totally
i feel it i believe it i think we need
to prepare for it
so we were using that and you know i
always say like
it is it looks in retrospect like really
amazing we totally predicted the future
we had
a whole scenario on supply chain
disruptions
that was a big part of it and that
definitely happened we had one of the
scenarios called power struggle was
about geopolitical disruption
surrounding oil and gas and fuel which
i mean has sort of happened on and off
one of the things we were looking at in
that scenario was what would happen to
countries that rely on
fossil fuels for their economy and would
they successfully transition their
economy out like some countries in the
middle east are trying to prepare for a
future now where the world doesn't need
all this oil
but then you have countries like russia
right now which is you know trying to
use gas and oil as leverage against the
rest of the world you can't sanction us
you need our fossil fuels and think
about
what might happen if we do make that
sacrifice
and say you know we're going to accept
higher prices we're going to accept
radical
temporary reduction in our carbon
emissions to not be held hostage by this
government um so that was the scenario
we were looking at i mean it's not all
it didn't all happen at the same time
but i mean i haven't seen if there's
anything we we said that was like super
super crazy i'm going to come back to
that because i'm i mean we had 10 we had
we had 10 predictions in evoke and we
had five in um
in superstruct but you know you don't
have to be like a genius you just have
to pay attention and not deny reality i
mean if you're willing to
have some trust in science some trust
and expertise
people know what's coming you know
people the the public health people know
pandemics are coming before they hit us
the next one they're worried about is a
tick-borne pandemic maybe it would be
fun for us to talk about it because it's
going to make us all allergic to meat
and think about living in a world where
we have meat allergies
well let me interject for a second so my
mom actually has
allergies to
mammalian proteins due to
the lone star tick in this particular
case oh my gosh so we have first-hand
experience and i've had lyme disease
twice so i
we both have first-hand experience so
could you elaborate on that and then
we'll we'll move on from the doom and
gloom but but i do think this like
pre-metatardial melorum as like say
seneca or the stoics might
word at this envisioning worst-case
scenarios as a
valuable skill or just
it's not even necessarily
obsessing on worst case it's it's it's
it's envisioning
what underestimated threats could be or
inevitable
threats if you just look at like the
secondary tertiary effects of of trend
lines that are already converging so
could you say more about this tick-borne
disease yes and i will say you are
absolutely right you do not have to
dwell on apocalypse so as i write about
a study in imaginable that showed that
five minutes of vivid imagination
was enough to overcome normalcy bias so
normalcy bias is when we believe that
the future will be like the present or
the past and we really underestimate the
actual risk or likelihood of novel
changes or disruptions
but five minutes of vivid imagination
and vivid imagination means not just
thinking abstractly about it but like
trying to go to the future in your mind
like it were a virtual reality world
where you can like look around what what
is you know what's the weather like
who's with me what is my body like in
this feature you're really trying to get
in it so one of the features i think
people should spend five minutes vividly
imagining
is a future in which this alpha gal
syndrome which i'm very sorry to hear
that your mom has it
it
affects more people so the numbers are
really rising we're actually doing a
simulation about this scenario starting
at the institute for the future tomorrow
i'm like super busy planning to kick
this off right now
and i mean the signals look pretty
significant in the united states there
are regions of the
country particularly in the southeast
where 33 percent of people have already
received at least one of these tick
bites and already have sensitivity to
this sugar molecule that shows up in
animal products so it's meat but it's
also
gelatin so if you're eating gummy
vitamins you know you can't do that
anymore it's it's there's gelatin and
toilet paper
to make it soft gelatin
encapsulation yes also if you take
capsules most capsules contain gelatin
and i was in i took my my family to
japan where i've spent a lot of time as
an exchange student and just
loved the place so i finally took my
family there and we had to take my mom
to the emergency room because she had
dessert
that had gelatin in it oh my goodness
often used for binding purposes and
it is surprisingly ubiquitous yeah so
you know in the scenario that i've
developed around it there's a meet is
everywhere
campaign public service announcements to
let people know
that sort of hidden
animal products but also
what they're starting to see is if you
have a lot of exposures to these
molecules even airborne meat can trigger
a really dangerous allergic reaction so
if somebody's doing like a cookout a
backyard grill even just smelling the
smell of meat cooking and so i'm just
trying to imagine you know what happens
to our our eating lives to our rituals
and traditions to
the restaurant industry to groceries to
the world if
one in 10 people on the planet are
living with this and it is you know we
when we come up with scenarios we're
looking for signals of change evidence
that certain futures are becoming more
realistic or more probable
ticks are now moving into areas they
haven't lived before in new york city it
used to be urban parks were safe well
researchers just found disease-bearing
ticks and all of the public parks in new
york city here in california we have
them on our beaches now which they
didn't used to be hanging out on the
beach the beach was a safe place now
there are
ticks on the beach so it's like this
sounds terrible
probably we don't want to think about it
we don't want to spend too much time
thinking about a future where we're all
living with this but
i promise if we spend five minutes
imagining it now
we will notice change faster over the
next decade if we need to prepare for it
we'll be ready we won't be shocked we're
not going to be in denial we're going to
be ready to help ourselves and others
and and you know so give it five minutes
just imagine waking up and
and some of your family members have
this alpha gal syndrome
or your employees do or students at your
school do it just what's different now
look around what are people doing
differently
what are some of the assumptions
underlying the expectation that this
will continue to spread
at a high rate i mean one of the
theories that i've come across just
because growing up on long island you
were in the
middle of the red on the cdc map for
tick-borne illness
and since certainly most people have
associated it with the
northeast right lyme connecticut
then lending its name to lyme disease
etc
but what are some of the assumptions
that underlie this the expectation of
growth one
that i'll throw out there is
uh climate change leading to
two issues in some cases overlapping
breeding cycles
but also
not killing
ticks
and therefore you just have this kind of
accumulation and multiplication but are
there other other things you'd like to
highlight
the climate change is the big driver
right now of increased tick populations
also
changing
how close humans live
to the wildlife interfaith so as we're
developing
into areas where we're up against
forests and mountains and other natural
areas we become more in contact with
animals that carry ticks another reason
that it might increase is if you have a
lot of exposure
to
meat and animal products
after you get
bitten by one of these ticks so the
first time it bites you you may not
notice anything which is why i say you
know 33 of people in the southeast have
already developed the beginning of the
sensitivity if you get another bite it
increases but also if you just continue
eating a lot of meat
you develop more and more sensitivity so
this is like one of those allergies
where the more you expose yourself to it
your body gets angrier every time
heightened immune response
so not just in the united states but in
other parts of the world
meat eating is on the rise as people
come out of poverty and they want to eat
more of a western diet and more protein
so it's not just happening in the us but
we're seeing in other countries
people are essentially setting up their
bodies to be more reactive
to this molecule so i mean one of the
things i talk about in the book is like
there is a preventive strategy like if
you
if you
you know were to start eating less meat
or exposing yourself less frequently to
this molecule if you did become impacted
you're less likely to experience such a
severe reaction that you would need to
go to the hospital not everybody would
want to do that but i mean it's it's
something you can do it's in your power
right yeah which i'm always looking for
things you can do
to feel ready be ready set yourself up
to
you know survive or thrive in no matter
what happens in the future
now just just to play
stand in for some people in the audience
they might say well wait a second i
think jane
is probably vegan or has some secret
mission to reduce meat consumption and
therefore is biased but let me let me
you can speak to that if you'd like but
let me just mention you know you might
just you could go the other way the
exercise doesn't have to lead that
direction you could also say well
and i'm not suggesting that people do
this right but it's not found in fish
reptiles birds or people so yeah
alligator farms ostrich farms i mean you
could go
yeah in a different direction right yeah
i mean i believe cricket protein yes you
can you can eat crickets you can eat
poultry i think it's still fine i think
yeah shellfish is still fine but it's
funny in the scenario i actually have
one of the things that we anticipate
happening is people who are convinced
that alpha gal syndrome is a hoax so
they think it's a lie perpetrated by the
plant-based industry to increase profits
or it's the work of a feminist militant
vegan global secret society called the
alpha gals designed to scare people into
adopting a vegan lifestyle and possibly
lowering their testosterone by eating
less red meat so we're already
anticipating the misinformation and
conspiracy theories you know what i was
vegan for a while i'm not a vegan
anymore so you cannot pin that on me i'm
not currently
although i do i mean i don't eat red
meats for whatever that's worth but you
know
i'm ready for this future
other questions and i don't know the
answer to this but for instance in the
case of lyme disease
uh and i'm not giving medical advice i
don't play a doctor on the internet
folks but
because i've had it twice and the second
instance which was very severe we've
talked about it before so i won't but
labor the point but
basically felt like i had early onset
dementia for about nine months joints
were so sore it took me five to ten
minutes to get out of bed in the morning
was forgetting friends names things like
this slurring speech
i waited for the appearance of symptoms
incorrectly assuming as many locals
where i grew up do that if you don't
have the bull's-eye rash you don't have
lyme disease incorrect there are many
instances
where dermatologically you're
asymptomatic but then develop lyme
disease so in my case again i'm not
recommending anyone do this talk to your
doctors but i always carry a supply of
doxacycline which is a common antibiotic
and in the case of any embedded tick so
not a tick walking on the surface of my
skin but any tick that is embedded and
just to paint a picture for folks
getting immersed like you said if you go
walking let's just say
in
montauk on eastern long island
and
you take hike on public land there's a
very good chance at certain times of the
year that if you pull your socks up over
your pants do everything right put on
some type of spray you'll come back with
10 to 20 ticks on you
and that is avoiding tall grass
so it's it is incredible
how much that density has increased and
you see different seasons where it's
just
uh absurdly absurdly dense however where
i was going with that is right if we're
looking at some of the
the ripple effects of of this type of
phenomenon or just this type of
story right the meme of
this prediction spreading if it were to
spread
does doxy or do other medications have
any prophylactic or kind of the morning
after pill like effects
on
being bitten by a lone star tech i don't
know right but if that were the case you
could envision a world in which
all of a sudden you have
10 20 different ripple effects just
caused by say stockpiling
antibiotics or other drugs absolutely so
antibiotics don't work to prevent the
sensitivity from developing but
one of the ripple effects that we
forecast in this scenario is
a run on epi pens because you might
suddenly have totally
you know going from hundreds of
thousands of er visits in the country
for anaphylactic shock
in a year to
tens of millions of er visits for this
and you know one of the things we talk
about well entrepreneurs will start
selling epi pen holders and you can like
wear it strap it to your thigh or strap
it to your arm there's like a fashion
that develops around the socks that we
wear over our pants like in the future
the instagram influencers are going to
be selling the socks that go all the way
up over your pants i mean you can
imagine
you know all kinds of things happening
but
i say like okay well what if you wanted
to spend five minutes a day feeling more
ready for this future i mean learn how
to use an epipen if you don't know how
to use one yet that's a good one learn
how to do a tick check you can actually
go to your doctor today and request
a test i think lab core will also do it
so it doesn't really matter you know if
your doctor's into it or not you can go
to lab core and request
a blood test to see if you have
sensitivity to the alpha gal molecule
yet so you can know if you're at risk if
you're not at risk like great because
again the first bite usually is not a
problem
but maybe you want to know that you
actually have sensitivity to this and
that might make you
try a little bit harder to avoid the
tick bites in the future now is this the
threat that you were alerting to earlier
that the world economic forum
had uh
put into the more current editions or is
it something else oh well okay so um and
i promise we're not gonna spend the
entire time talking about threats as
much as uh yeah people follow enneagram
i'm a self-preservation six so sorry
but
what was that threat well and this one i
think there's like a silver lining to
this threat i'm actually kind of excited
about this threat if that sounds a
little bit weird and twisted
the number one most underrated threat
was global youth disillusionment so
basically young people
saying eff it i don't buy
how we've organized society and
i'm out i'm not doing toxic productivity
i'm not doing the capitalist grind i'm
not
you know i'm not going to live my life
the way that
that global capitalist forces want me to
and
if you want to look for evidence
where do we see evidence of global youth
disillusionment i don't know if you saw
there was a landmark study published
in february of this year in the lancet
planetary health journal
and it's the biggest study of its kind
ever they interviewed over 10 000 young
people aged 16 to 25 in 10 countries so
every asia the middle east africa europe
north america latin america um and they
found that 56
of young people
feel that humanity is doomed and they
personally have no future
two-thirds said they primarily feel
anxious
hopeless or afraid of the future and the
number one reason that they gave for
these feelings
was confusion about government failure
to act on climate change like they
literally think
the world is going to burn
and
they're they're not here for anything
except radical dramatic action and you
can kind of see
also little bits of this and like the
great resignation
in the lying flat movement in china do
you know about the lying flat movement
i don't but tell me more what is lying
flat movement it's just young people
saying
sorry i'm not going to get a full-time
job i don't need to spend all this money
you don't have to pay me so much because
i'm just going to
buy less or live at home with my parents
that would make me happier and so it's
like lying flat like i'm just gonna lie
down and literally they lie down a lot
but it's more of a meme this idea is
that i just don't believe that this is
necessary like this hustle this grind
this global grind
it's not good for the planet it's not
good for my mental health
and i don't like it and i'm out and so
the idea that
i mean on one hand this is posed you
know by the world economic forum as a
global risk or threat because what if
young people just don't want to do the
work anymore right what if they don't
want to buy the stuff anymore
what's that going to do for the economy
but on the other hand i don't know i i'm
i'm kind of excited for
well it's also a risk because people who
are disillusioned
i shouldn't make light of this people
are disillusioned are more likely to be
drawn to extremism and terrorism so that
is also
that is a major risk
and i also find it exciting that we
might be you know kind of like the 60s
was a big a big decade for social change
and just
radically changing our norms about
gender and race so fast
maybe we are going to be able to ride
the wave of global youth disillusionment
to
something that i think could be better i
think i mean i'm
i've been radicalized a bit by you know
the seven years since we last
spoke tim you and i i definitely uh
i definitely want to see
big
radical crazy change
let's if you're open to it just chat for
a second about the sort of unspoken
subtext of that statement
so what is kind of a lazy question but
with respect to what you just said what
has happened for you or what have you
felt or whatever you come to realize in
the last seven years
i mean i've learned about
modern monetary theory which i think is
super interesting have you ever had an
expert on modern monetary theory on your
show i don't know if i have not i have
not i definitely encourage you to get
someone on to talk about
how countries with sovereign
monetary systems can afford to do more
than we are i won't try to be an
economist on this but
there's a new understanding of money
that makes it possible for us to really
seriously imagine universal basic income
which
i've i've gotten more informed about
universal basic income and how it
changes people's physical health their
mental health there's less crime i mean
it's just it's a good thing for society
so i've been kind of
i don't want to say radicalized because
i don't think ubi is a radical idea but
i'm i'm on that train i want people to
work less and care more right care for
their kids care for themselves care for
their communities
i've seen the numbers on the four-day
work week which i think isn't going far
enough i'm already imagining a three-day
work week as
a global norm
because
because we honestly there's no reason
with automation
with ai
there's no reason we need to work this
much i mean every time we've invented
new technologies of productivity
economists have predicted that we're
going to use that to create more free
time for leisure and cooking
hasn't happened it it only happens when
companies experiment with shorter work
weeks the only thing that actually leads
to
people spending time on themselves and
each other in ways that benefit them
physically mentally socially and
emotionally is when the boss says
well i'm going to pay you the same
amount of money but for a shorter work
week and it's been tested on as much as
20 hour work weeks i mean i know you you
know all about working less but you know
they've been able to pilot 20 20 hour
work weeks which i actually think is
the ideal in terms of you know you know
like how much productivity do we
actually have in a day
you know for especially for people who
are creative or they're thinking they're
producing
four
to five hours a day is the absolute max
that's it
the consensus pretty much for almost
every
writer
i've spoken to and i like the writing
example because it's quantifiable both
in terms of time and in terms of output
say just words per day
is
around four hours is where a lot of
who i would consider very productive
many would consider prolific
writers max out per day so we're looking
at let's just call it
25 to 30 hours of concentrated work in
that case per week
let's see what else can i tell you about
that
part of being a futurist is you get
exposed to new ideas and new evidence a
little bit faster so you can you can
kind of get excited before other people
so one of the one of the areas of
evidence new evidence that i'm excited
about is looking at
programs that give free
basically unlimited fruits vegetables
fresh produce to people who want it not
means testing so not not just like poor
people not just people who are on food
stamp programs but just take a community
give them a bag
say you can fill this up you can take
this to any farmer's market or grocery
fill it up with
whatever you like to eat any any fresh
fruit or vegetable it's totally free
programs that give away this kind of
food for free to people see such a
radical improvement in health such a
dramatic
decrease in health care costs these
programs are being piloted all over the
country people who are interested can
look for the food is medicine movement
it's a coalition of food producers
health care who subsidizes this who pays
for this so the government is actually
the u.s federal government has given
money to these programs to test it you
would never know about it i don't know
why this is not more common knowledge
it's like hidden away in some farm bill
i mean it's
there should be more
awareness of this and then there are
also philanthropists who are funding it
there's health insurance companies doing
pilots because they think they can spend
less money on healthcare of people if
it's just easy and you know what i love
about it is like it creates this feeling
of abundance so in the in imaginable i
ask people just imagine you have this
like
tote bag with a qr code on it that's
attached to your profile so you can take
this bag wherever you want once a week
and just get whatever you want for free
and just how good that feels and we can
imagine that when we go to a market we
can look around and just imagine what
would i and the feeling of abundance
instead of scarcity
of of having what we need
the emotional quality like this is not
just a physical health intervention this
is a mental health boost to to feel like
we have what we need
and and this i don't know i if we can
create more abundance in the future any
way we can do that we fight less
we there's less you know sense of other
people as being
competition
if we all have what we need
that's a world where we i think we can
be a little bit happier and nicer to
each other and i would like to live in
that world
so i'm going to ask you about urgent
optimism
in a moment
in a moment first i want to just bounce
some
non-professional
thoughts
slash
i wouldn't say in some cases predictions
off of you and just
get your thoughts so the first one is
you mentioned universal basic income
and
what we're already seeing in places like
say the philippines with axi infinity is
people playing to earn so playing a game
earning income to the extent that there
are so many players
on some level they represent such a
significant percentage of a politician's
constituents that they can now impact
elections
and
this trend i think is only going to
explode i don't see any countervailing
force maybe there's some regulatory
action but regulatory action
is often determined by political action
politicians like to be re-elected so
it really depends which is the same way
that say uber took a lot of cities right
they could harness the power of their in
this case users and drivers but mostly
users not even people making
their livelihood automatically
to
kind of overthrow policy in a sense
overwrite policy so that's one i'll
throw out a couple of do you want to
comment on that first there's so many
things about what you said i'll throw
two things out at you okay so
one aspect of it is cryptocurrency right
and in axios infinity they're earning
money by essentially mining
cryptocurrency as they play
there is definitely going to be
regulation you know biden's talking
about setting up regulation of
cryptocurrencies the scenario that i
think is most likely in the space
because of all this unregulated
exchange of income and wealth is that
governments will absolutely create their
own cryptocurrency sent centrally
like central bank cryptocurrencies and
there will be incentives to not use what
are now what would you call a
traditional cryptocurrencies that are
unregulated or unattached to a national
bank there will be financial incentives
so in china right now they hate they
hate bitcoin they're banning it they
want people on a government
cryptocurrency so they can track every
transaction they want to know where your
money's going there i mean china is a
surveillance state right they're giving
it away for free hey try this new
cryptocurrency here's a bunch of money
and they want to get more of this
currency into circulation so that it
replaces traditional cryptocurrency and
and then they get the data
and people have sort of been you know i
don't want to say
lured into it but uh
100 percent alerted they're being bribed
with money on a hook
but i think it's something so one of the
dilemmas that i post unimaginable is
would you take that offer you know let's
say you can trade in your traditional
crypto or traditional cash
for 20 interest
a hundred percent interest one-time
offer are you you know are you
and i want people to imagine being ready
for this wave of regulation but also for
this wave of potential financial
opportunity if you're willing to use
a government's cryptocurrency
that too could be a big
wealth generator but i think people will
be paid to play games through a
completely different economic system
which is the game companies themselves
sharing
getting into a revenue sharing system
with players because we know you look at
roblox
people already getting paid for creating
games within this
gaming world or ecosystem
the companies are
trying to figure out how to make gaming
sustainable and healthy and and viable
for the long run and so we are going to
see
definitely ways to earn a living playing
games but it might not be
in a crypto sense it might be in a more
traditional
sharing revenue sense and i'm very
excited about that
it's another just to not i don't want to
take us too far down like crypto
metaverse lane but
another question that i have as i think
about this and there are many
experiments being run right now in the
sense that you have axe infinity as one
very large scale example although in the
grand scheme of things i think
still in the first inning you have
companies like so rare which tether real
world performance and sports too
not just virtual gaming but then betting
on top of that it's fascinating
and you know one one question that has
come to mind for me is i'm thinking
about
the secondary tertiary
and so on effects is
which
occupations will first or most likely
experience mass defection right brain
drain
so who are we going to lose which
services
are going to experience a gap that may
not be automatically filled by
automation if the automation is slower
in terms of mass adoption
than the play to earn which i think will
i do think will will take off but those
are some of the questions i'm asking let
me let me throw out a couple of other
ones so another is
a i created or curated
whether with attribution to some team or
anonymously
in effect cult leaders right or
religious figures
yes
because you can
you can
presumably ingest vast amounts of data
about a potential target population or
craft a particular
figure who is nearly indistinguishable
from
a photorealistic human
and china has already of course china's
is far ahead on a lot of this uh and
they've they've had even as as recently
as i want to say
maybe two years ago so i'm sure the
technology has improved dramatically but
they had
real newscaster ai newscaster
same person side by side and the test
was to see if you could tell the
difference and it was hard
it was really hard
you are hitting on something very
important i mean we are definitely
entering into decades of essentially
cognitive warfare and we are definitely
going to have to protect ourselves one
thing that i've seen
that
makes me
you know pay attention i want to be
alert to this future is the blending
of
people in your social network
with the face
of this like
artificial persona that they've so let's
say there's a cult leader that they want
to establish a following around
you can blend that person's face
with the face of a person's mother
father romantic partner
and create it's just the slightest tweak
you and i would think we were looking at
the same
cult leader phase but the algorithms can
go to your social network
pick your closest relatives or people
you interact with most often on the
network use their faces to slightly
transform the face of the cult leader so
every single one of us is seeing now i
haven't seen examples of cult they're
just doing this in studies right just to
be clear but
where you can and then people trust they
say how trustworthy does this person
look to you
well the trust goes up when their faces
are blended
relationship with the family member
but yes i i get the basic idea but i
mean so it's not hard to imagine
how this i mean it's it's like trust
warfare it's taking
people that you have trust in
and hijacking it to build your trust
they can do it i mean right now it's
being positioned primarily for
politicians
as a way to make yourself look like
somebody a person would want to vote for
you just slightly morph your face to
look like someone's mom
or for marketing to make like like
spokespeople more
relatable
100 we're going to see that happen i
mean like 10 years from now you and i
are going to be like ugh can you believe
that
this working well of course we believed
it we we were we were good but how do we
so that the game becomes
what do we do about it
how do we you know and so you know
a lot of people are interested in moving
to
a more of an audio culture and audio
information culture because there's so
much
deep fake video and so much deep fake
imagery being generated by ai that we
might have a longer timeline where
the audio landscape is more
factual or trustworthy
i'm going to push back and say there's
deep fake audio all right it's
horrifying horrifying but most people
but this is great i love how you're
pushing back because i've i've er the
the technology exists but what does not
exist yet
is the data sets so whereas we have
facial information about virtually
everyone on the planet unless you're me
and you've recorded
yeah i'm funny broadcasters are the
i'm
600
first people at risk here so i think
about that future because i'm often
asked by technology companies to think
about unanticipated harms of their
products and services they don't want to
wake up in 10 years and realize they
just destabilize democracy again or what
have you so all of these smart speakers
that we talked to
right and so we're talking to
siri or alexa we're the google assistant
well that's learning a lot about
our voice and it may be that early
adopters of those devices if those
systems get hacked
are at a new kind of privacy or security
risk the way we used to worry about like
our social security number being hacked
maybe our audio
signature being hacked might become or i
mean but you know this is still in the
realm of play like i still think this is
fun to imagine it's not as serious
enough it's not like you know the alpha
gal syndrome where like oh we should
really do something right now we're just
playing with ideas and we're thinking
about
how our actions today could lead to
you know a better or a weirder
more riskier world well let's get weird
so
i encourage people to listen also to my
last conversation with eric schmidt
around ai it may make you want to curl
up into the fetal position and just weep
but
i think a lot of these things are closer
than we expect and so that leads to my
next question which is one i probably
wouldn't ask eric but i will ask you
because we've we've spent some time
together and
i feel comfortable asking you because
your your sort of breadth of exposure
and thinking is is very wide
in this world of looking into the future
so let's talk about
two things i guess sort of physical
augmentation and manipulation so let me
say one thing about what you just said
also earlier
if
someone has data on your likes and
interests presumably one could you like
rihanna great when we show you an ad for
a fill in the blank
and we know you're a female we're going
to like take 10 of her attributes and
blend them into whatever a i face is
talking to you
but if we look at for instance some of
the trends that i'm already seeing i
mean my girlfriend showed me
a number of filters on instagram that i
could not believe i mean people are
using these filters and it turns them
into you know 9 or 10 out of 10
attractiveness
models right it's
pretty mind-boggling to see the
side-by-sides
and
so my next question is going to be
related to sort of porn and virtual sex
because younger as i understand it i
don't have the the the direct source or
citation for this but
it seems to be that
that younger generations are actually
having less and less sex and there are
there could be many different causes
there probably are
many different causes but
it would seem to me that in a world of
kind of ubiquitous beauty if people are
able to modify that
and ubiquitous kind of extreme sex
that a certain insensitivity develops
right where the real world pales in
comparison
and
you know i follow
vr
less so ar but vr reasonably closely and
i do think you know ready player one is
probably closer than we would like to
think
but
i imagine when you have technologies
like neuralink
and direct direct
you know computer brain interfaces which
could be good for a lot of things but
my my feeling is that you know virtual
sex and kind of immersive porn
is is probably not going to use haptic
suits so these suits
that just have like a vibration in your
chest or something is very dissatisfying
ultimately when it gets to certain types
of things like if you're getting shot by
a ghost in a video game fine but if you
are having sex with someone probably not
the sensation you're looking for but
it's it seems to me that
that as with many technologies you know
porn
is going to probably drive a lot of the
pushing the envelope
yeah so this is a very
it's like no one will ever admit to
going to pornhub and yet it's like the
fourth most visited website in the world
or something
how far away do you think we are from
that or how do you think about this
because i think the
destabilization that it will exert
not just upon
people productivities the disruption of
relationships possibly
procreation putting aside the kind of
children of men movie type scenarios
which is a whole separate thing
i mean that this could even be i could
see it being weaponized where like their
i mean politicians get involved because
of the sort of macro effects that these
things have maybe i'm just spinning a
science fiction yarn but
what are your thoughts okay i'm like
taking so many mental notes as you talk
by the way tim you are an excellent
futurist
i want to invite you you have visited me
once at the institute for the future i
would like to invite you back sometime i
want to pick your brain for some of your
wild scenarios because they're they're
informed right you talk to so many
interesting people that you you hear
these signals coming so
let's see okay
so first of all yes definitely porn is
almost always at the vanguard of new
technologies it's one of the biggest
drivers of adopt like sex important will
drive adoption of new technologies
there's a huge interest in neural
implants as you suggest i do think there
is considerable interest in developing
neural implants first wave will be for
mental health for treating
intractable depression and suicidal
ideation that will be the first wave
second wave
maybe sex and fun and you could
definitely imagine a society in which
our
orgasm needs are met
by a neural implant rather than through
physical sex and what i
find
fascinating to think about is you know
could we map out
all of the possible consequences maybe
some positive maybe some negative but
what happens when we don't
have to
have physical encounters essentially to
have and we're already we're seeing that
through porn
but the difference between neural
stimulation is it wouldn't need to use
imagery so i actually think it would be
better in some cases
to get an orgasm through neural
stimulation rather than through porn
because a lot of the porn that's being
created today
is i think really
um
what's the word i want to use there's a
lot of violence
in it that if you look at the research
for why people are younger people are
having so much less sex
the biggest reason that's coming up in
the research right now is that women see
the choking the slapping the hitting in
the porn it's become
normalized and they don't
want
to be choked and slapped and hit they
see sex as more violent than it
traditionally has been and so we've got
this whole generation of young women
who
look at the imagery that's being
consumed and produced and think like i
don't know that doesn't
seem
seem like something i actually want to
be experiencing
if we didn't have to be creating these
visual
representations and we could i mean
people might actually come back to sex
if they weren't being shown versions of
sex that they personally did not want to
participate in may i add something to
that yes
because it's all crazy and hypothetical
yeah i know i think a huge part of it
is
that
males become desensitized
to
the appeal of let's just call it
everyday or normal sex because if you
can have a threesome or foursome with
like
you know
nubile young women who will
enthusiastically do anything even if it
doesn't include violence and
these other sort of acts of aggression
let's say it's not that let's say it's
just all fun and games but if you kind
of have access on to man to the most
outrageous fantasies that you could
possibly have
instantaneously with broadband i think
there is a desensitization also
i think sex drive from males who are
i think if we want to call spade a spade
typically sort of initiating
interest or sexual advances
you know if if they are constantly
depleting themselves
physically there are kind of physical
self-regulatory mechanisms that will
lower sex drive
so i do think that's a huge part of it
right and it could change culture i mean
if men are just acting differently if
women are acting differently so much of
society is right now oriented around
finding sexual partners
you know our our grooming our our
physical routines our social encounters
i mean like our dreams our hopes that we
imagine for ourselves
if we were to put that time or energy
now let's say but i'm i'm positing that
we're not getting addicted to this
stimulation it's highly regulated and
the way that like you can't
i don't know buy
more than x amount of
stimulant medication you know it's
controlled i'm assuming it's going to be
controlled if it's not we're in a lot of
trouble
but you know people like just pouring
their energy
their their male energy their female
energy their their gender energy into
whatever
else they might want to do other than
just trying to find a mate it's going to
be really interesting like in a way it's
as radical as not having to work 40 hour
work weeks and the time and energy that
frees up for other things
if we're not i think it is so
fundamental that it's
i i think it's going to rock
everything i it's because
you know i was looking up the source you
know oscar wilde said everything in the
world is about sex except sex sex is
about power
now put it putting aside the meaning or
the interpretations of the last line for
a second which i think is interesting
but yes that's a whole separate podcast
but it's it's like if you look
at i'll just speak from the male
perspective because like
i mean the vast majority of what men do
in this world certainly up and up and
sometimes exceeding the point at which
they have kids
revolves around
sort of
preferred
mating abilities that's it it's like all
of it the [ __ ] cars the [ __ ] money
the power this is all yes going straight
to sex
when you start to remove
yeah that incentive in the real world
holy [ __ ] oh my god i love it okay tim
100
i'm committed
i want to simulate this future so so we
have a scenario club a new scenario club
at the institute for the future it's
like a book club but you just come and
talk about different future scenarios
each month and we imagine ourselves and
what might happen in the ripple effects
and uh i'm gonna do this year
a future of sex scenario for our
scenario club which by the way is open
to the public so i hope people listening
who are like
incredibly
have their brain on fire thinking about
this possibility that you have put in
front of us they should come to urgent
optimists which is our our future
imagination club and uh and they should
join scenario club and
and come imagine the future of sex with
us this year because i am you have you
have planted that seed i'm gonna water
it we're gonna we're gonna see what it
goes into
and uh on which
website can people find that that is
urgent optimists like plural because
there's a bunch of us.org
okay urgingoptimist.org we'll also put
it in the show notes cool so let's let's
lest we
allow the apathetic
youth amongst us
just turn into you know some version of
12 monkeys or worse
i encourage everybody to re-watch that
movie by the way should also re-watch
ready player one and children of men uh
and possibly re-read snow crash but
that's us all separately we need more
movies about futures we want based on
that list that you just
i know although you know you were
chatting before recording about my my
conversation with margaret atwood and
she writes a lot about near-term kind of
dystopian
people would consider dystopian futures
but she's very optimistic
which is which is interesting so let's
talk about cultivating
optimism uh or definitions of optimism
what is
urgent optimism
so urgent optimism that's actually a
phenomenon i first identified when i was
studying the psychology of gaming so
something interesting happens
with people who play video games often
is there's a certain neural circuitry
pattern that gets really strengthened
and easy to activate that involves the
reward system and the learning centers
that makes us feel
like i got this it's like it's like the
neuroscience of
i can do this and we feel more physical
energy more mental focus
more hope that something good could
happen more expectation that we can make
something good happen through our own
efforts and actions and abilities and
what my research eventually showed was
that essentially every video game is
like a psychological experiment it's
like a training ground to convince
people
that they have power right you go into
the game you make choices you take
actions the virtual world changes
you get better you're improving your
skills you're achieving goals this whole
experience and journey of essentially
building the sense of power that we have
to impact the world and how the future
of the game turns out
what i've tried to do in my work is
figure out how do we develop that
that sense of power and the real
ability to
get new skills and achieve more
ambitious goals in relation to reality
and in relationship to the future so
that we're not just feeling this when we
play a game but when we think about
the future of sex or the future of food
or the future of religion or the future
of democracy whatever we want to think
about
that we feel that same sense of urgent
optimism that i know for sure there are
things i can do today
that will impact how the future turns
out
for the better through my own power and
there are three habits
that you can practice that build urgent
optimism
by the way the the best way to do it is
just to play these future simulations i
mean that's like the fast track that's
the cheat you i tend to um as you've
probably noticed
when i play out the future scenarios i
almost always go negative
that i think is part of
my superpower so it's like i've been a
sockovid coming from a mile away i was
able to prepare make a lot of decisions
that were great decisions early
but i'm sort of constantly future pacing
to the next disaster right that's
it and people like what they're good at
it's like
stretchy flexy people like yoga even if
yoga didn't make them stretchy because
they get to be like the michael jordan
of the you know hatha flow or whatever
the hell
so
good i'm glad you said that so urgent
optimism does not mean
thinking that everything is going to be
good it does not even mean imagining
better futures in fact urgent optimism
is often something we develop by
thinking about as you said the next risk
or threat or disaster but the key is we
have to practice these three habits and
like take we have to take it to a full
cycle you might be stopping
someplace where we don't get
we actually it doesn't actually feel
good yet so we got to do these three
things to feel good story of my life
yeah so so please please continue sorry
to interrupt oh no problem okay so the
first step is mental flexibility so
mental flexibility it's the opposite of
having a fixed mindset or being stuck in
assumptions that the future will be like
the past so to get mental flexibility
you're always looking for these signals
of change you're paying attention to
weird stuff that's happening that maybe
has never happened before you're putting
kind of your ear to the ground so that
you can notice change faster one way you
can increase mental flexibility besides
just trying to pick up on these signals
of change is just to vividly imagine
scenarios that other people would
describe as unimaginable or unthinkable
so like we're just trying to go to this
future of sex with the neural implants
and we're going to the future of where
we can't trust video or faces anymore
when you put yourself into this future
and you just what would it feel like
when i when i look at my computer screen
what emotions am i feeling what am i
seeing that i've never seen before
that
overcomes the normalcy bias so the first
thing you're trying to do with urgent
optimism is just to
not be the person who gets stuck saying
that could never happen or like ugh i
don't know i can't even imagine it so
i probably don't have to worry about it
we're trying to improve our ability to
imagine things that never happened so
that's mental flexibility
the second practice is realistic hope
so realistic hope and i'll give a really
good just
like trick for this but realistic hope
is having a balanced mindset where you
are both aware of the risks and threats
it makes sense to worry about and
prepare for and ready ourselves for
but also all of the new technologies the
new policy ideas the new solutions
social movements all the positive stuff
that could make a better future or help
us avoid these risks or transform it
into something that is a world we
actually want to live in and one of the
simple habits that i teach people to do
is just
go to google
and type solution
for whatever problem you're worried
about you know
solution to climate change instead of
just worrying about climate change type
type it into the google news and see
what weird solutions like learn more
about carbon capture learn more about
geoengineering and solar radiation
management we have to fill our brain
with
the pathways forward
as we're also holding in mind the risks
and threats and this is just like i mean
most people tend to have more of one
than the other so we're trying to
balance it out
who may
i just want to add one quick thing
because this is a good place to put it
just in the process of doing research
for this conversation
i found another example of using google
that might be this is from you that
might be helpful also for that
improvement of kind of
future focused imagination of the
so-called
impossible or unimaginable and that is
making a
list of things you're interested in like
food travel cars city you live in shoes
dogs music real estate this is from
slate.com and i think it's from your one
of your courses at stanford
which is how to think like a futurist
and it is
once a week just do a google search for
the future of dot dot dot yes once a
week so i say make it fridays future
fridays easy to remember like that and
you just type into google and i suggest
google news because what you're looking
for is
new stuff that you don't already know
about so
you want the latest
and yeah you type in future food and you
can learn about you know let's say
lab cultured meat like maybe that's
something that you would be interested
in knowing that you know maybe you're
vegan today for animal cruelty reasons
but in the future there will be
actual meat tissue grown in a laboratory
condition without an animal having to be
killed like that might give you hope for
the future if you're like kind of a you
know like you would rather not be vegan
but you know you don't want to you have
you have your ethical concerns so yeah
you just type it in future of whatever
and collect that's what that's those
signals of change and it helps you build
your mental flexibility i don't have to
be this way my whole life because the
future might give me a different
opportunity things don't have to
continue the same way we can do it
differently
so we got to i think we got through two
right we got to realistic hope
what else do we have okay so you got
your you're mentally flexible you're
practicing realistic hope the last thing
is future power future power means you
can make a list of things you can do
today
that help you either be more prepared
for the risks and that you're worried
about or prepare for an opportunity in
these future worlds
or that will change the world in the way
that you want it to change so you're
like collecting these just little
actions so i'll give you should i give
you a few examples of like things that
have been good for me okay
learning how to operate a drone for me
very empowering drones are clearly going
to be a huge part of our culture and
infrastructure in the future
i want to know how to operate one
particularly the ones with cameras
because that is really interesting to me
it's interesting me for art for
storytelling for journalism for
documenting human rights violations or
being a witness to things that the world
needs to know about for all of these
reasons i just ordered you know the the
not an expensive drone a cheap drone on
amazon and learned how to fly it i
taught my kids
before seven years old now right i
taught my daughters how to use it too
because it's just something fun and easy
we could do
to be ready for
a future in which
it would be good to know how to use a
drone
another one
have you heard of adversarial makeup
no i have not all right you got five
minutes go find a youtube video for
how to apply makeup
that interrupts the algorithms used in
facial recognition
so that's cool because during the
pandemic people people were like well
we'll just wear masks and we'll if we if
we don't want to be surveilled by our
faces we'll wear masks well during the
pandemic there were so many people
masking that all of the big facial
recognition companies
had to learn how to recognize people
just by this little band of our eyes and
it actually the pandemic actually
inadvertently
made this huge
advances in facial recognition because
companies now they only need to see this
little bit but you can apply eye makeup
to
throw these algorithms off their game
and
it's better than wearing a mask i think
you know it's more comfortable it's more
social and it's fun and it's expressive
so yeah you know we might wake up in a
world not too far from now where people
on their phones have facial recognition
apps i mean we're not just talking about
the government or police having this
technology we're talking about it being
in every dating app in every social
network i want it who's that person like
learn all their stuff about them so you
know you want to be ready for this
future take five minutes
learn how to apply makeup to interrupt
it i'll give you one can give you one
more because um you can give me five
more if you'd like i'm not a rush
so
one thing that i really want to
recommend people
do in five minutes if they haven't done
it yet
is to install
an app on their phone
that can be used to create a mesh
network so do you know do you have do
you have any mesh network capabilities
on your phone yeah all my phone no i
don't think i do on my phone i do have
i have used mesh networks and i've used
them at home but please explain
this phone except you can get an app
like bridge fi and what they do is if
the internet goes out during um extreme
weather
during a government mandated internet
shutdown which happens in dozens of
countries right now
india is a big
internet shutdowner
to kind of control information and
prevent people from organizing
so you can connect you can essentially
make your own internet right so if you
have enough people with this mesh
network on your phone
you can communicate to somebody's phone
within a football field's distance and
they can communicate to someone who
feels distant so if you get a community
or you get a an urban center a bunch of
people you can essentially recreate the
internet using just the bluetooth
capacities of your devices now amazon is
actually
trying to
do this as well kind of secretly like if
you have
a smart speaker from amazon they want to
essentially have it be ready to act as a
mesh network which on one hand people
like oh i don't want
information being connected with other
people's devices but you know to me my
mind goes to the future where the
government's shutting down the internet
for cyber security or to stop
misinformation or because it's an
authoritarian government and they're
shutting it down
and you know we have a company like
amazon being like not so fast here comes
our mesh network and they bring up this
like totally alternate internet so they
can't be stopped by the government which
by the way in the united states it's
written to the constitution the
president can shut down the internet
it's legal scholars have recently looked
at this and basically the same
communications act that allows
the president to shut down
you know mail and phone they he could he
could shut down the internet too she
could shut down the internet
so get your phone ready to make your own
internet put an app on five minutes
so i have not used that yet i will i'll
try it out
although i guess there might be a
chicken in the egg kind of situation do
you need to convince other people to do
it or just kind of like yeah or is it
like google maps where it's it's
gathering data because so many people
already have it installed
there has not been a tipping point yet i
would say so i mean it's you're getting
there early as we like to say at the
institute for the future you you'll be
one of the the people who lets others
know hey get get your phone ready to be
in a mesh network in case we need it so
right now yeah spend the first five
minutes putting it on your phone and
test it with like someone you live with
a friend a partner whatever test it so
you know how to use it
and then if you have to converge you
know in an urban center at some point in
the future to like recreate the internet
you'll be ready but it'll help if more
people have it so you might spend five
minutes also telling someone else to put
it on their phone
so another uh technology that i don't
understand well so the engineers and
computer scientists out there
may have criticisms but
is helium which is
in effect
to create decentralized wireless
infrastructure and is is very much web 3
based i didn't realize that helium.com
that must cost a nice pretty penny hope
they had a good broker for that
but
what you're describing and
then thinking of helium and other sort
of alternate communications means
uh have you done i imagine you probably
have scenario planning
and we are going to come back to these
three steps i'm going to ask you about
specificity training also
but before we do
let's talk about blackout scenarios so
whether that is through
cyber attacks this is very current news
right i mean the possibility of cyber
attacks on the grid yeah the possibility
although i think it's less likely but a
a brute force attack with say uh
electromagnetic pulse bomb over the
great lakes or something like that
there have been books written by people
i would consider informed and credible
about
yeah this type of threat
have you done any scenario
simulations around that
i did do a simulation called dark after
dark
where we asked people
to practice
not using
anything with artificial light source
after sunset
this is for a slightly different
scenario than the blackout scenarios but
it was an interesting
way to develop essentially calluses for
a world in which you might not be able
to
open up your laptop or turn on your like
that we would have
darkness true darkness again
and we were we were that was an
experiment in just
how people's behaviors would change and
how much they were willing to change so
it's more of like an experiment than a
future forecasting
serious future forecasting effort but i
i absolutely think it's worth preparing
for i mean just even in general the
reliability of our
power grid
is very much
weaker than it used to be we saw what
happened in texas suddenly there was
extreme oh i was there you were there
for that tim oh my gosh i was very
involved in trying to
get you know water and so on
yeah people who if that had gone on
three more days i mean there would have
been thousands of casualties yes yes we
just got lucky it was pure
just meteorological luck yeah so two
things around that so one is you be
aware right so now we have mental
flexibility
that
maybe we can't expect
the power good to be as reliable in the
future that's the first step right we
acknowledge the possibility right and
then we look to
look to places where we might have more
power to avoid or survive or change it
right so
i mean a lot of people that i know are
thinking about climate migration right
now they're starting to think about i'd
love to hear more about that oh that's
my obsession climate migration is my
number one
personal
mission i'm on to prepare people
for up to a billion people to move and
possibly to have a incredibly
more open and transparent immigration
system than we have today so that people
aren't trapped behind
borders and climate hell but also in our
own lives even moving internally within
our country in california
so many people i know are like um
i don't know if i want to live under
extreme wildfire threats for three or
four months a year i don't want to live
with this air pollution from the
wildfire smokes i don't want to live
with power being preventatively cut off
i don't know if you've had this
experience where i was in i was in cali
and yeah pg e rolling blackouts and all
that stuff and they just shut it off
because they they haven't put the wires
underground so when there's winds they
just turn off your power for up to a
week
and you just have to you're expected to
work
and learn and live
and cook even though literally they're
just like no power today so we have to
make we have to think now about
where we're willing to live or what
we're going to raise hell about like
getting power lines underground i don't
think a lot of people have that as their
number one thing to protest and raise
hell about but we might want to think
about
securing our power grid as
as as something as
worthy of radical activism as as what
we've seen social movements in the past
around
and is the
getting lines underground aside from
being more aesthetically pleasing is
that to
prevent easy sabotage or are there other
reasons in your mind it's just more
secure underground in every way
in california
we're having more
wind high wind events right so they just
snap and then they spark a fire and then
it's three months of hell
so
that um that's the main reason but yeah
it increases security
overall
and so it's you know one of the one of
the games at the back of imaginable it's
called welcome party and it's an
invitation to explore your own tolerance
for climate risk
so there's a set of questions to ask
yourself
at what point is it a tipping point for
you to leave how many days without power
a year how many days of extreme air
pollution you know just
asking these questions now so that you
don't wind up like the frog in boiling
water who never hops out
right yeah totally and just a
recommendation if i get through
something out there because i live in
texas
uh clearly a broad spectrum
of political
allegiances and
broad spectrum of beliefs that go along
with that if you sort of accept whatever
the party has as its ten commandments
and so on
uh i think that climate change
can provoke a really strong negative
response in a lot of people
but
if i simply word it as
increased extreme weather events yes
you sidestep the whole thing the other
the another piece i would say is whether
or not you believe that this is
human caused largely or in part skip
that part of the i know i know this is
going to be controversial i'm saying
just to get the foot in the door if
you're talking to someone who may be
resistant to that because that will be
one of the first fights that many people
want to pick you just say forget about
that
let's say this is a natural event
nonetheless if we want to
actually maintain our infrastructure
and
do a b and c we have to contend with
extreme weather events so let's just
assume it's all natural it doesn't
really
doesn't absolve us of the
necessity and advantage of
thinking about how to cope with these
specificity training
yeah what is specificity training i know
these two words separately but in the
context of what we're talking about what
is this can i put a pin in that really
quickly because i just thought of one
make it a pincushion go crazy
i was just thinking of one practical
thing we could do that
that your listeners might like which is
can i just
tell you the three questions that you
can ask to measure your urgent optimism
and give you a sense of which of those
three habits or skills you might want to
practice more
so it's really simple and i i'd say you
can pick this for any topic so it might
be the future of psychedelics for mental
health treatment might be something
you're interested in or could be the
future of
of college education to pick a specific
topic and then you ask three questions
when you think about the next 10 years
how much do you think
this topic will change
on a scale of one to ten so one is
almost no change everything stays the
same 10 is extreme change almost
everything is dramatically rethought or
reinvented right so on a scale of 1 to
10 how much change do you expect 1 to 10
on a scale of 1 to 10
when you think about the changes that
are likely to happen in the next 10
years
are you mostly worried or mostly excited
about them so one is extremely worried
10 is extremely excited and then 1 to 10
how much influence or control do you
have personally in how this change
happens
and so one is almost no controller
influence and 10 is almost complete
control or influence and and and not
only is it helpful for us to think like
oh i need to practice some more
realistic hope find some reasons to hope
if i have a low number or i need to pay
more attention to the world economic
forum's global risk report if i'm like
out of 10 maybe i should try to learn
more about the risks
it's so cool to share numbers with
people and man do i love talking to
people who are at like
sevens eights on nines on topics that
i'm at
one two or three about is super fun so i
just wanted to put that it's like a
practical fun for you talk to people
about it share your numbers and think
about how you might practically increase
your urgent optimism on on the ones that
you have lower numbers for could you
give a personal example for yourself on
a
particular topic industry
situation that we haven't discussed yet
it could be one that we've talked about
if if that lends itself
but uh that would be super helpful for
me because when i hear these questions
i i can see the value in answering them
and
i find that my default so i'm not asking
for a solution to my particular
malfunction here but i think it
correlates very highly to the kind of
existential malaise and apathy
of a lot of young people although i'm
definitely too bearded and too bald to
be considering myself young at this
point
nonetheless though
i can answer question one pretty easily
for most things and then i think
generally i skew very pessimistic yeah
i have a very hobbesian view of humans
in general which is maybe another issue
and then three with respect to like the
agency
sometimes i feel very little agency or i
feel a lot of agency but i don't know if
i want to be
just like
going through
just a forest of headaches and
difficult humans with a machete for most
of my time yeah if the upside isn't
certain so could you give an example of
something uh
in your life that that you've sort of uh
applied these questions to
let's go back to drones so drones create
a lot of anxiety in people for good
reason they create
noise pollution they create visual
pollution they can be used for
surveillance remote policing privacy
intrusions warfare warfare right and i
started seeing drones just out in the
world seeing signs like no drone zone i
didn't know is that a law is that a
recommendation i realized i didn't know
what the rules or policies were around
drones i didn't know why why are we
spending so much time and money
developing this technology all i ever
hear about are
you know a lot of the risks so for me
drone was a space that i wanted to
explore and maybe build some urgent
optimism and and not optimism in the
sense of i'm going to become an
evangelist for drones and i'm going to
feel like the future is great i don't
have to worry about it anymore but to
increase my confidence that i can
imagine a future with more drones i
understand what it might means the risks
the opportunities and that there are
things i can do to be ready for it or
help shape it
so i started
talking to people
looking on google scholar finding drone
hobbyist communities what are people
using them for that is not terrible
right so i learned about witness.org
actually has a drone training program
for people to
document war crimes human rights
violations authoritarian governments
doing terrible things to create
irrefutable evidence right so to be a
witness for this
as drones as a form of activist
journalism and documenting reality
i learned about the emotions that we
feel
when we look at aerial footage so drones
it turns out can create a kind of
visceral
feeling that i don't even know if we
have a word for it yet it's it's a
strange new positive emotion
where we have an almost this kind of
god-like omniscience because we're we're
seeing everything from above we're
moving we're like swooping through the
air like again eagle there's an
incredible new positive emotion that we
don't even have a word for yet that
artists can use storytellers can use
therapists can use by using drones to
to give us a viewpoint we've never seen
did you wanna yeah i was just going to
say my my ask of my audience is somebody
come up with a clever german word for
whatever that
and
put it online because there's there's
got to be uh some way to slap a bunch of
adjectives and nouns together into it
and get that done thank you tim that is
that is an amazing suggestion
um what else did i learn i i went to
google news and was like just show me
what people are doing with drones right
now and i learned that
just a couple of months ago the first
organ was delivered for a for transplant
that they couldn't get this organ i i
think it was a heart they couldn't get
it there fast enough except for
delivering it by drone so the first
emergency medical delivery so learning
about the positive uses
while also learning about you know well
what are what are the rules and policies
like who decides i mean to me this it
became fascinating rather than anxiety
producing to expose myself to
who is in charge of drones is it the faa
yes in part is it local
parks and recreation yes in part because
in order to have future power we have to
know
who's making the rules right because i
need to know what the rules are who's
shaping them who's advocating for what
it's like
building urgent optimism it's like it's
like following
following a string out of a labyrinth
it's like you're taking all these twists
and turns
you're you've got your radar up so
you're going to hear about weird new
risks you're going to hear about cool
new uses and i like to think it's just
like it's essentially a process of
opening your mind and if there's
something you care about
this these habits of looking for the
clues and
if you're negative looking for well
who's excited and what are they excited
about to kind of create the balance
who's in charge who's who has power now
so you can even understand where power
is being concentrated what are the
companies that are most advanced in this
technology it's it's literally just
it's a practice it's a practice like
meditation where
we just have to kind of show up with
this curiosity actively
collecting these clues
every day
so i can see how
the
pursuit
of the of the sort of metaphorical drone
as you follow the strength through the
labyrinth with doing this type of data
collection
would help a lot with answering question
number one
when you think about the tech in the
next 10 years do you think things will
mostly stay the same or or will they
change tremendously kind of one to ten
number three i can see how you figure
out what you may be able to do whether
that's learning the technology whether
that's buying a predator drone to take
out other drones i love it which are
being used in many contexts including
sporting events and so you could you
could figure out sort of from an agency
perspective what you can do to
increase the good decrease the bad
i'd love to talk about mostly worried to
mostly optimistic one to ten mm-hmm i
got you and this is a very personal
question because i tend to focus on the
negative because i'm like hey
we didn't last this long by
under-reacting to threats right humans
are programmed to kind of overreact to
threats
for survival purposes and
not saying that should be the case but
it's like i
even if we're all screwed and going to
just die in a fireball of self-imposed
disaster there are times when i would
like to not think about that and be more
optimistic
even if it's just a suspension
i mean that is literally why
i run social
simulations because i don't want you
going into this mental spiral of
doom and gloom
first of all people are at different
places
naturally in terms of
pessimism or optimism anxiety or hope
just we're born that way there's a
hardwired nature it's a biological
component
when we do these social simulations when
we play scenarios with scenarios
together you come to the scenario club
you're going to be exposed to all these
different points of view and it's it's
why
it's why
it works for me
jane mcgonagall the game designer to
have become a futurist because like what
are the most fun games to play it's
really not the game you play by yourself
it's the game that you're playing
in big groups unless it's vr
neuralink porn then maybe but
yeah good call back
right but you know we really like these
big game worlds we're all playing
together it's world of warcraft it's
league of legends it's pokemon go we
want to be in community we want to be a
part of a bigger game so tim you got to
get out of your own head right and you
want to it's like but
it's easier than i mean you can do this
yourself you can go look for sources of
hope yourself but like so for example in
urgent optimists we have a week-long
signals of hope scavenger hunt every
month it's a group chat you just sign up
for the group chat and everybody sends
each other the signal of change that
makes them feel most hopeful for the
future and we have different categories
that you can go look for like show me a
signal of hope around the future food
show me a signal of hope for the future
of climate adaptation and
it's i mean you're basically flooding
your brain
with it's a it's an active habit you
have to you have to
intentionally expose yourself
go look for these positive clues but if
you're not good at it then get yourself
in a community the same way when i
learned to meditate i didn't do it by
myself i went to a sangha and i went to
sit in a room full of people who already
knew how to meditate so that i could
develop that skill and be held
accountable
so i you know i like to do this futures
work
with with a community to hold each other
accountable to see the risks and to see
the reasons to be optimistic
teamwork makes the dream work yeah i do
need to
get out of my uh sort of
hamster in a wheel in my own head
i'm going to mention a few things and
then i'm just going to pass the baton
and you can pick up whichever one you
want i know i'm mixing up my singular
and plural here but
okay choose your own future forces
journal from
future or journal from the future
the first five minutes of the future
which which of those would you like to
snack on right now great well we did put
a pin in specificity training so oh yes
we did absolutely perfect
so journaling from the future it's a
form of specificity training so what is
specificity training
if
most people when they try to imagine the
future there's just too many blanks
right if i were like imagine yourself
waking up 10 years from today
it's like your brain is like
like you could imagine yourself waking
up tomorrow you know what room you'll be
in what bed you'll be in maybe what
you're sleeping in what your body will
feel like you have your particular
moment in time if i say 10 years from
now are you going to feel better or
worse are you going to be with a
different partner or not
we don't know is there gonna be extreme
climate change and you're going through
some extreme weather
it's harder to fill in the blanks so one
way that we train our brain
to be able to think more effectively and
creatively about the future
is through practices that increase the
specificity of our imagination the
number of vivid details
and you can actually measure if if
somebody's like okay i imagine waking up
and it's uh it's really hot because
there's extreme heat in san francisco
now which is really weird we didn't used
to have temperatures over a hundred but
now it's like 110 every day like you
could go back and count the number of
details 110 that specific that's more
specific than just saying it's hot and
you can count every color every sound
every emotion i'm feeling dread because
i don't want to run my air conditioner
or whatever i'm feeling excited because
i have access to this new thing
every detail counts and you can score
yourself on the specificity of your
imagination and one technique to improve
the specificity of your imagination
which is linked to
again more creative thinking more
effective thinking better strategies
more motivation to do something
specificity is good
you keep a journal
from the future where you write detailed
entries of what you might experience as
if they had already happened so you have
to treat the future like a memory and
you're trying to capture it or you can
think of it as like journalism but most
of us are better at just writing a
personal diary than some kind of you
know journalistic account and when i run
these social simulations of the future
the main thing people are doing
is just keeping a journal so okay i woke
up today and i got the lab results that
i do have
alpha gal syndrome i've initial
sensitivity
this is how i felt this is the time the
phone rang this is who i told i told my
husband first like you you start to tell
the story you imagine it in vivid detail
the number one thing this accomplishes
is that it obliterates normalcy bias
once you have vividly imagined a future
it is literally imaginable and you will
no longer deny the possibility you will
not underestimate the risk you will spot
evidence of change faster this is why my
book is called imaginable because
because we want to be able to imagine
the world either that we might wake up
in or that we create through our own
actions that is better than a world
today but so yeah so you know any of the
scenarios that listeners have heard in
this episode
they can just go do this now like
literally pull out a notepad it i find
it works better when you write by hand
because
you don't want to like edit or censor
yourself so we recommend free writing
you set a timer for five minutes and
just write for five minutes whatever
comes to mind with as many details as
you can
pick one of these scenarios future of
sex future of deep fakes future of
whatever we were talking about
jerome
you know art and storytelling whatever
whatever you want and just write a
journal entry from this future it is
it it will literally change your brain
forever that future is now forever
imaginable to you and it only took five
minutes
who's alvin toffler ooh alvin taffler
wait before i say who's alvin toddler
the other thing is when we write these
five-minute journal entries we can share
them with each other which is how we get
out of our own heads so that's another
reason why you write it down right you
don't just want to imagine in your head
because i want tim i want to read your
journal entry i've done enough of that
so alvin hoffler he
he essentially
created
popular
future thinking as we have it today so
in 1968 he wrote a book called future
shock
and it was coming at the end of this
incredibly turbulent time in the united
states where
where our our
gender norms were changing there was a
civil rights act finally passed the
economy was changing people were feeling
like they were unmoored new technologies
and and he had the theory that if too
much changes too quickly
that it is like a trauma we get shocked
we feel overwhelmed we feel paralyzed we
feel hopeless unable to cope and he was
observing
that there was almost like this mass
trauma too much future too fast in the
60s and so he had this idea that we
could essentially
prevent future shock from happening
again if we were better able to imagine
the future before it happened and to
prepare people to actually train people
he had this crazy idea that didn't
really come to pass
where
whole cohorts whole generations would
would you would form like
clubs like almost like we have a book
club today or like bowling clubs but you
would come together to practice new
future skills and it would become this
like rite of passage instead of getting
a driver's license you know you come and
you learn these like 10 new future
technologies to prepare you so that you
don't feel shocked i mean that does
actually sound kind of fun to me
so yeah he was trying to get us ready
and he kicked off the field and
all of us who do futures work today we
kind of owe him a debt of gratitude for
recognizing that how we feel about
change
is a huge driver of society's health and
our own psychological well-being
now i believe this is from the new book
imaginable as it relates to alvin
toffler
that
he had a maxim which is just truncated
in front of me but
i'd love to just hear you explain or
expand on this a little bit is more
important to be imaginative and
insightful than to be 100
right in quotation marks yes
could you speak to that and any other
sort of maxims of his that uh that you
like
here's the problem with trying to be
right about the future and there are
definitely people who are interested in
this there's like a whole other school
of futurism called super forecasting
where you're just trying to be as
specifically correct as possible what
will the price of oil be on this date a
year from now what what is the you know
exact number of troops that will be sent
into this conflict you're trying to be
very
and people try to be as accurate as they
can
what hoffler was saying and what i
believe to be true
is
what's the point of being right other
than you know you can feel smart you can
say aha i told you so maybe you can like
protect or prepare yourself but what if
the future that you think is most
possible the future you think is most
likely to happen
it's not a good future i mean do you
want to be right or do you want to
actually
prove yourself wrong
and
help us all wake up in a better reality
so this obsession with being correct
about the future even though i'm proud
of having accurately foreseen certain
changes or certain disruptions
i would be
much happier if
we never
wake up in a world you know where alpha
gal syndrome is so common because
we all
got more sort of interested in tick
health and like nobody gets tick bites
anymore cool problem solved that was a
stupid scenario that never happened i'd
rather be wrong and so alvin hoffler's
trying to encourage us
and i encourage everyone is we stretch
the imagination to consider what's
possible and we look for clues as to
which possibilities are plausible and
what might make an outcome more or less
plausible and then we decide we take
action to make the future we want more
plausible or take action to make
features we don't want less likely and
that's the power not not accuracy
it's the ability to imagine
and take action that we're really trying
to get better at
i'm going to ask you about
technologies or approaches or plausible
technologies approaches that you're
excited
about or
have spent time on related to
extreme weather events aka climate
change or carbon removal et cetera but
before i get to that i'll just say
i think one of my challenges in finding
optimistic people to act as a sort of
countervailing influence to my inherent
like innate pessimism
is
i'm so [ __ ] tired of techno optimists
who are like yeah yeah yeah we can do
whatever we want like we'll figure it
out later that stuff drives me crazy
but to be fair
you know humans are really good at kind
of spotting
obvious trends and i can't remember the
exact timing but at some point you know
the price of oil was going up going up
going up going up and
someone projected well by this point in
time you know
this day of the year ten years from now
five years from now like it'll be a
bazillion dollars per barrel and like
china will overtake us and this this and
this underestimating or missing
completely the fact that when the price
of oil gets to a certain point
technologies that are currently
economically infeasible or that yet
haven't not been created because the
cost is too prohibitive suddenly become
very profitable like fracking and so on
and so that predicted feature did not
happen so there is something to be said
for
people underestimating the rate of
innovation but the the kind of yeah yeah
it's all going to be fine
techno optimists stance that you find at
the extreme really drives me nuts so i
would
love to know because it's a personal
interest
with
climate solutions or regenerative
agriculture carbon removal what do you
think are some of the most interesting
things that you're seeing or expect to
see
very good i'm so glad you asked this
question because
i don't see
these technological solutions as
requiring techno-optimism so much as
they require
socio-optimism meaning that we would
somehow find a way as a society to
enact these potential technological
solutions so the very last scenario in
imaginable and it seems to be everyone's
favorite like
people just love it
it is called the 10-year winter and it
tries to imagine how we as a society
might decide to go all in on solar
radiation management which is a real
geoengineering technology that has been
in many people's opinion and my own
grossly
under-investigated and experimented with
because people are
rightfully worried about unintended
consequences
but many people also believe that there
is absolutely no way to keep this planet
inhabitable
in as much you know space as we inhabit
today if we don't want to run out of
two continents worth of livable space we
probably are going to have to do
something
to control temperature while we get to
clean energy while we sort of stop
carbon emissions so that's going to take
a while we may need to explore things
like solar radiation management where we
just partially block some of
the radiation and so we're trying to
cool the earth by injecting sulfate
particles into the atmosphere there are
scientists ready to test this there are
there are
delivery devices that have been created
they want to send them up into the
atmosphere they want to test can we send
the stuff up there
we want to run simulations and models of
you know it might create
maybe inadvertent flooding or flood risk
i mean there are things that will have
to be grappled with but if we don't
start talking about and imagining it now
we're not gonna have time to actually
develop the technology in the process
you know who decides to do
geoengineering are we going to let one
company or one country unilaterally act
i mean what if china just says whatever
we're done with climate risk
we're going to solve this problem
we're just dimming the sun for the whole
planet like you can thank us later
is that going to be possible right now
the un has a moratorium
on all
geoengineering experiments and efforts
it's it's like
treated the same as setting off a
nuclear weapon they want to stop people
from doing it we need mechanisms to
debate discuss educate
and innovate so that if we have to do
this
we're not doing it stupidly and we're
not doing it in crisis mode so i am you
know man do i want people to start
thinking about
what would it be like to possibly
have to make this call who do we trust
to make it how will we get informed
consent from humanity to do
geoengineering that's going to take a
while to figure out we need to start now
like today
talking about
how we will accept this risk if we need
to take it and how we will
try to mitigate the harms for people who
might
be harmed by unintended consequences
yeah it sounds like a great scenario to
to role play also because i can imagine
if you look at property rights in the
united states for instance i believe
that
there is ownership of some degree of
airspace i don't know what the
limitations are but above one's land
property let's say
so
i would i would i could envision
especially countries that are being hard
hit harder hit perhaps than other
places
in the first world who or they may be
first world themselves
deciding
if it hasn't been sort of specked out
already
from a legal and political perspective
that they own the airspace extending all
the way up to the end of the atmosphere
and
god it seems
if we can't coordinate around covet on a
global level
exactly unlikely that we're gonna get a
calm conclusion consensus and
peace-building effort on this
for politicians who are incentivized by
short-term rewards largely and i should
say just because i want people to know
this about you that
you also study
incentives and we don't have to spend a
lot of time on this but i do recommend
that people read i believe this is a
piece you wrote for wired and it was in
uh tell me if i'm getting this right
it's it's on wired.co.uk but related to
lotteries and social problems
and
using prize wheels say for
in patients who test negative for
opiates and things like this so
i want people to
appreciate that you're not just
kind of waving your hands and saying
hope people figure it out you're also
studying the mechanisms by which the
positive rewards or negative rewards
right if there's a in a sense i mean
it's kind of hard to categorize this but
like
regret lotteries for weight loss studies
which you have to forfeit your winnings
if you haven't met your weight loss
goals yes which is actually super
effective had an economist on the
podcast recently who talked about the
effectiveness of a clawback incentive
which was what that would be
do you have any recommendations for
people who would like to
study
incentives and how they might apply
because we're all self-interested
creatures and i guess the trick is to
make us whether we like it or not
beings who act in enlightened
self-interest even if it's just to
better ourselves we end up bettering
others
any resources they could be in any of
your books it could be in articles if
people want to learn more about
incentives
do you have any thoughts
you should look for the new game theory
so
old game theory which comes out of
economics and to some degree political
science assumes that we're all rational
actors and we're going to do what is
almost mathematically the most
optimized we're going to choice we're
going to make it we're going to take it
and people were winning nobel prizes for
it for decades and and people today i
think are waking up to the fact that we
make choices for all kinds of irrational
reasons and
a proper game theory a new game theory
should take into account things like
we're more motivated by regret
the fear of regret than
than other forms of psychological
incentive that take into account
that we we actually like to inflict
suffering on people that we have a
frustration or we have uh
we have perceived
slight in the past that we can be
motivated intensely by
humiliation i mean like there's so many
incredibly powerful emotions that drive
our behaviors and trying to essentially
invent a new game theory that does not
treat people as rational actors because
if anything we've learned over the last
couple years is that
people will make very irrational
decisions based on
emotional
and psychological drives
are there any names any
any writers or places you suggest people
go if they want to dig into that um what
would be you think they'd search on
google
let me come back to you for the show
notes how about i send you let's send
your let's send your fans to the show
notes for follow-ups on that because i
wanna i wanna i wanna get something good
for them okay we will add those to the
show notes everybody tim dot blog slash
podcast and just look for jane you can
search chain you'll be in good company
you'll be right next to jane goodall
so people will have all the the
superstar jane's in one place and you
can find this
i would also recommend people read
there's a book called chimpanzee
politics
which is fascinating it's written by a
field biologist but i believe this was
used by
newt gingrich at one point or so he
claimed to help sort of seize control
and
fascinating
there's a lot of overlap a lot of
overlap
between us and our our dear cousins
so jane
people can find you on twitter at avon
game you can find you on the website
jane mcgonagall
m-c-g-o-n-i-g-a-l dot com the new book
is imaginable subtitle how to see the
future coming and feel ready for
anything even things that seem
impossible today perhaps especially
things that seem impossible today and
we'll include a link to imaginable in
the show notes as well and you can find
it everywhere books are sold
is there anything else that you would
like to
add today anything else you'd like to
discuss or uh request and ask of the
audience anything at all that you'd like
to
to say before we wrap up thank you tim i
mean my big ask is that we do not waste
this historic opportunity that we have
to
create the change we want to see in the
world so you and i we've talked a lot
about
the futures we don't want but we might
wake up in any way how to be ready but
there has been so much change so fast
over the past
two years that
i think we all realize
that the kinds of ideas we would
previously have dismissed as unthinkable
or unimaginable we can change right we
had a failure of imagination we were
stuck
we just saw humanity do things that
would have seemed completely ridiculous
and impossible changing how we live how
we work how we learn what we value
so
i just i
i you know i wrote this book not just so
we could be ready for the hard stuff but
so that we can all
see ourselves as being gifted with
an unprecedented opportunity to create
positive transformation people are ready
for change our minds have been broken
open by the pandemic and all the other
crazy stuff we've lived through the past
couple of years and so you know let's
let's see ourselves as living through
a truly
historic and special
valuable moment we may never again have
this opportunity to create
quite so much transformative change so
fast and i want to just
ask everybody
like don't waste it let's not waste this
moment let's truly change things that
need to be changed
here here and
you know it can be as simple as doing a
few exercises
to envision the future so that you feel
a greater sense of urgency which will
give you an indication of the steps you
can take
now right the small steps that you can
take even if that's just
finding drone hobbyists so that you can
have some
selection of of positive implications of
the technology
and to see how you can steer away from
towards that or away from the negative
and
jane i just love our conversations this
is so fun for me
i've taken a million notes here i didn't
get to ask you about cookie rolling
which that's going to have to wait for
another time
but i i really recommend everybody check
out the book i think these are
first and f i mean to my mind like first
and foremost like psycho-emotional
tools
for developing not just resilience but
like anti-fragility which is different
right it's where you can thrive and
train and help others to thrive in what
are
certain to be
uncertain times
and
times of great flux i don't think that
is going to slow by any stretch of the
imagination so i do think overwhelming
change or potentially overwhelming
change is the new normal
right
and so i'm so happy
that you've written this book people
should check it out again folks it's
imaginable subtitle how to see the
future coming and feel ready for
anything jane has a good track record
very good track record and has thought
very deeply about this so she has not
just the theory but also the street cred
and i recommend people check it out and
uh you know i say that too because i
just love hanging out
and what a what a fun conversation so
thank you for making so much time
yes absolutely my pleasure and i hope
you know i hope we get to revisit this
conversation and see
see how our imagination lines up and and
we can talk about the actions we took
and and what we actually accomplished
so i will look forward to that 10 10
years from now tim you and me 10 years
from now
maybe sooner and and for god's sake
people go buy just a few hundred dollars
worth of backup water like for [ __ ]
sake i don't know why i've seen this
everywhere over and over again hurricane
sandy the austin freeze and they're like
that was a hundred one in a hundred year
storm it'll never happen again and then
there's like a year or two later it
happens just like if you have a fire
extinguisher in your house or you wear
your seat belt when you're driving down
the highway buy some extra water you can
go a long time without food anyway think
about backup power too so
i'll leave that for my uh my prepper
send off
and jane i'm so excited about the new
book i'm so happy to reconnect
and uh for everybody listening we will
have links to everything we discussed uh
jane will also send some resources to my
team to put in the show notes about
new
versions or new iterations of game
theory
such that
we don't model the world after the
assumption that humans are rational
robots
because clearly
we are not
and
i think the resources section will be
really powerful so that will be at
tim.podcast just search jane and it'll
pop right up
and until next time everyone
be safe out there be just a little
kinder than necessary
train yourself to be optimistic
don't just sit in your house doing uh
laps around the couch or chasing your
tail in your own head
and thanks for listening
you